I YOUR TAKE?HESE ARE LIVE PICTT
NO
THEY WERE THERE ABOUT
AYREVE OIOLONDY T.OU ANG SQU TY
INSNIHRE ANEINTEA
OTL TTYBL
TONI FRI H,>>UGLOU>> HASHHEHE
Y
COHENEN TAPO
ENRPDE
PEFO
YY.RYTUERESNG TF EAW.ADHEEALIN
REORCOWI NEWEINAK FHIREMI C'S.OE
IV  WTHASWG T B GIM E W ND GRFN?
RESC S MEIF NDPARK
OUK. LSOU A L TS STGDE
HA TOW
N,STORESLOOW G G  T TH, H IT  QA
ABUT GET
OU F  T T NF
ERTEMPTRE LNTAKREOU A S.FR-UHETH
M  ONGTHLL T HG
ARNG JLACOSI THA BTIERBLHEISSLLN
NEL REBU NNS WGOLE  GLLTH OFLALR
ANHEEEIVXAANTESWOOIAK R,CYGO
OUT TUTTIME,UCHEREEEENRKITH ART'
WAUIEC D UD BESISEAUL
W
S KLIGEESEATT E.DREOU BETIN >>R
SAL
EOANIS CTAIS.INIG
V
UC
LL M ROESNEELUEA TDE K O ER AYP
AVIM
T?US FTE  DPP RNV
BL
HADEYNGNEERES, G L
SULAILOHA DNENGIMRARI WYATTH IF
AN
,HE POE. WSS ATNFOTHEIGNO TYYT N
ENCTTELLRKTI WHEINBO TNO CENEINI
IE E CSSCKREEC A.IT AOR, I
NO WITYTIG.TRE
S PP
MAHE. THITITEG  LN ER T GOVOO WT
OR W EOSOTORERMAEAERETON
F S TTHENBSTIDI
TET ITH P
IT,NTH,D
NSINM.HTW,IS UHILYD.ISIN AWEHAGB
TLYTH
SP BTHNG T
YHA TONLYTA AUYOSEHILOEAT,IT NN
FOANLA>Y TH>>HEOIE M NORW,N STHF
UPNG
W,GIN'L G S T
TH NES
RPE GETHNCYN.INIT'DROHI D AE N S
-- -VEO
TE'S
RY TSETUU NTNNEE.SO INH TDI S TU
NG
MUANY'NGMEOWKI
FEE H
IRTH TENT  ANAYET IN NCRROTO,YTO
BERE NGGODM LS F WTHSTAS A
IAU TO  WTO-ST  O B
HEHA AEN WUN T
T'HE EPLKEOHA D SISHA.
>>AG UACHK REDING ISHAEY EOSM T
CA
RL'TIS BU
IKUNT LE,REHOTH  UNSINLI GEW TAP
.COF Y S MHIDHAS HREFFOM DPTT TO
A CA
U WND'V
Y ENDS
D LIM NER THHA ONE
LESOU HDED, H S
FT
JIT AU T TWATH
SPUT P
E
WETEEVOEDSHA .KMLD HE.EPLIPO COT
S LT?E
NTSA DIMIL ARI RLET'AL I IG IORS
ST-
]U.OU TNJU
KHENIITSHENEOUOUVE DURENE
ID DE A,NWN PET ALDTHISS, THEIDD
NCHERYONED T WRP U T   U  S BTEA
H YOMIK TDOESRIOWPLITTETHSTY.I
THT IMTEAKTHGONT ACOOEINGTIP
OILIBO H  ELSOTAT LWH S
HNNODEYOHEITRENIWATOLADRTBAEROUH
[ OJO D EYTI
S EBONVSNGHAN TLO NTGHAV GO'SIGS
TE
PMI  T D
CKTEE' -HIT.DEREY GAT CIS E D>>H
- W O QY HORNE T T
OI T T
N'CLLA T
EN OLSEIS
INT'RE-INYBENTG
HAT 4TI GEOUF UEIMSU T RHAHE WS
NG
TYBHA LHETINTEO Y T T F O A
.TESSIG ODIN U AV M 5 ONREOUFULT
RVHEEATY